this is in again in the oregonian on
august 27th
ohsu ends massive coronavirus study
because it underrepresented minorities
university says uh this is about a key
to oregon study which had been projected
to cost 24 million dollars every year
was to track 100 000 people's
coronavirus symptoms
and when it was announced in may
governor kate brown called the program a
game changer
sounds great
quote one of its original goals was to
make sure people of color signed up to
participate but that did not happen
follow the link in that article
and find this from ohsu this is no
longer the oregonian this is ohsu's
actual
news release from august 27th as well
ohsu ends covet 19 study supports
ongoing conversations between black
indigenous and people of color
decolonizing research and data council
and governor's office
to better understand disproportionate
impacts of the virus within communities
of color in urban-based indians and
tribes
so so yeah fairfax here didn't like that
last bit
the claim is and it's a claim and this
is this is the point here the claim is
that there are disproportionate impacts
of
the virus okay um
paragraph three of this good lord cat
um paragraph three of this news release
from ohsu
reads specifically covet 19 has
intensified the profound and
disproportionately adverse public health
impacts that have long harmed
harmed black indigenous and people of
color as well as other historically
disadvantaged populations
including but not limited to latin x and
hispanic
asian and pacific islanders it is
critical that the state improve its
understanding of code19 prevalence by
centering research on the communities
most affected okay
this is why they have um they have
shut down this this major study that
appeared to actually be doing some
some good because because
they say they did not manage to attract
enough bipac people of color black
indigenous people
to the study and therefore they were not
able to keep track of those once again
the claims are
um sorry i'm looking the
claims are that those people suffer
disproportionate impacts
and uh that they are the communities
most affected those are direct
quotations from the ohsu news release
we find again in that in that first
article i showed you quote the program's
failure is a major hit to oregon's
effort to monitor study and ultimately
curb the pandemic
the pandemic has affected black people
american indians and pacific islanders
particularly
hard with case rates many times higher
than those for whites
with a link okay let's follow
the link that they are giving to support
the claim they just made okay
so this is a fairly long um a long
report and here i got to move you kitty
cat
um and it's it's pretty good
it's published again august 26th so the
day before
um this this gets shut down
there's a whole lot here a whole lot of
uh
a whole lot of numbers and at first you
just gotta wonder where is the evidence
what are they talking about where is the
evidence
so take me off this for a moment zach so
i can just i don't make people
dizzy by scrolling down to get to table
three
nope that's age group table three is
uh the only thing that i can see from
this that actually shows
that actually seems to address the point
that is made
um that this is being linked to so this
is table three for those just listening
severity and rates of covert 19 by race
so if you look at the fourth column
cases per thousand
you see that in fact black american
indian and alaska native
and pacific islander populations indeed
have a higher case rate
um of over a thousand or in the case of
pacific islander
almost three thousand this is per 100
sorry per hundred thousand
um for those demographics whereas white
and asian
um uh people have uh cases per hundred
thousand of 281
and 393 respectively okay so
um that is certainly one measure
of the effect of um
of how much people are being affected by
this virus right
and we know of course that focusing on
severe symptoms now and deaths is a thin
metric and we've been pushing against
case focusing on case fatality rate for
instance and just deaths
for a while now because uh we know that
there are lingering health effects for
people who've had copenhagen and we can
therefore suspect we are predicting that
there may be very long-term effects
from this disease so i do not in any way
mean to minimize
people who have had cases that weren't
severe
however let us look at the two other
measures
on the screen zach if you would show
that again please
on this table of of the effects of covid
percent hospitalized and case fatality
rate percent hospitalized
um for whites blacks asians american
indians etc
is all basically the same they aren't
giving us raw numbers
or maybe i actually could maybe we could
even do a
chi-square with this um but those those
numbers look all
pretty similar right i mean you know
blacks are
um hospitalized at slightly lower rates
than whites and asians and
american indians but i really don't
think in pacific islanders but i really
doubt that that's in any way significant
so those numbers basically look the same
but if you go and so
by that metric if you're looking at
percent hospitalized you would say
actually none of the demographics if we
if we're looking at demographics by race
are more or less affected which is a
direct
i should point out here there's one
potential confound which i think you're
about to rule out
in your final category here but one
thing hospitalization rates
could have something to do for with
access to services
could be yes yes that a disproportionate
if if blacks were disproportionately
affected they didn't show up in the
hospitalization rate
because for whatever reason they didn't
go to the hospital and maybe because we
know there's a correlation with class
and so you know people who are poorer um
whether or not it's because they're also
more likely to be black or less likely
to go to the hospital even when they
need it
we would then predict that the case
fatality rate would be
higher again that the cases per 100 000
and the case fatality rate
would be comparable even if
hospitalization rate wasn't
but when in fact we see in this final
column
of exactly the table that is linked to
as
evidence that black american indian
pacific islanders
in oregon are being disproportionately
affected by covert 19
is the case fatality rate for whites and
asians
is two to three times higher than it is
for blacks
and for american indians and for pacific
islanders
so it's more than double so how is it
that they can claim with a straight face
and literally cancel
a study a long-term study that actually
was
maybe going to do some good on the basis
that it was not
successfully encouraging enough people
of color to come and be participants in
it because those people are inherently
the most affected by this crisis their
very data
show that they had to pick and choose
they had to cherry-pick the metric that
they used in order to make that point
they had to cherry-pick this is not how
an
a university with health and science in
its name this is ohsu
this is the biggest most premier uh
hospital and health and and university
by many metrics in the state of oregon
what are they doing this doesn't look
like science this doesn't look like math
this doesn't look like healthcare it
looks like bad science it looks like
verification of science and so that's
the thing cherry picking is the method
for verifications where they look and
you know we saw this
across the board in the evergreen fiasco
where
a vast amount of data existed and it was
cherry-picked in order to suggest a very
particular narrative about
people of color being left behind by
evergreen when the data actually
frequently reflected exactly the
opposite
exactly that the college was doing well
by its students of color so
anyway cherry picking is the hallmark
of verificationism which is the hallmark
of a dishonest attempt to
advance a narrative above the facts
yeah and in this case the thing that i
find most striking about it
is that it's not as if the study was
accidentally constructed to exclude you
know in
the way many medical studies have
excluded women you know because men are
a convenient study group maybe there's
bias that goes into choosing men but the
point is
you know you can have studies like this
that are
non-representative for some reason but
in this case they specifically went out
of their way to recruit
bipoc people they apparently failed to
attract sufficient numbers
for the group that is claiming they
didn't detract sufficient numbers right
which doesn't suggest that the study
discriminated against these people it
suggested these people discriminated
against the study and the idea that you
should
not collect data right because
people who you tried to include didn't
end up included
for whatever reason is preposterous
because
you know the fact that that's that's
shut down stem right there that's
successful shut down stem
they win it's successful who loses
everyone everybody they think they win
but they lose too and so do all the rest
right so the fact is the the thing
that's hard to wrap your mind around
here
is people are actually going to die for
lack of data yep right people are
actually going to contract this disease
and they're going to die
because the data is not going to
properly inform them about the symptoms
that arise
in this which you know frankly the
symptoms if you're following something
that tells you what these symptoms are
like
are frightening enough to spook you into
being very careful about this disease
knowing what those symptoms are is going
to be key to protecting yourself and how
they unfold you know you and i have been
advocating
now for more than 40 live streams for
the collection of large-scale data on
the progression of the disease so that
we understand something
about how it works so yes this is shut
down stem and the result is going to be
humans are going to die that's right
that's what happens when you shut down
stem
we need better stem we need
hypothesis-driven research to once again
become the thing that people are doing
when they say they're doing science
but shut down stem people will die
that's what will happen
people will die and you won't know their
names which is going to make it easy to
ignore
right you won't know which people died
because of the lack of of this data
that's right so is the nature such as
the nature of complex systems